en jazz gas gas tess 11 septembre 2001
al-qaïda frappe les états unis oussama
ben laden devient l'ennemi numéro un des
américains
très vite la tête de ben laden est mise
à prix par les etats unis 25 millions de
dollars mais où se cachent les
terroristes en novembre 2001 deux mois
après les attentats les américains
pensent l'avoir localisée dans les
montagnes de tora bora à l'est de
l'afghanistan selon les américains à 55
km au sud de djalal abad se trouverait
là grottes de tora bora une installation
ultramoderne creusé dans lé flanc d'une
montagne de 3900 mètres
les responsables d'al-qaïda sont ils
dans ces abris ultra moderne ou dans des
grottes beaucoup plus sommaire comme le
prétend le document du cameraman afghans
personne ne le sait et les avions
américains cherchent toujours ben laden
est introuvable ses rares apparitions se
font à la télé ou sur internet
dans des messages sonores ou vidéo comme
si en 2007 dans cet enregistrement
le terroriste provoque et menace
implicitement les états unis quelques
jours seulement avant le sixième
anniversaire des attentats oussama ben
laden exhorte ses partisans à
intensifier le combat contre les
américains
leur but en irak et de nous expulser
s'ils veulent le faire c'est parce
qu'ils cherchent un sanctuaire
un sanctuaire pour lancer des attaques
contre l'amérique et contre nos alliés
c'est la dernière apparition de ben
laden dans une vidéo le fondateur d'al
qaïda est partout et nulle part à la
fois au pakistan au yémen les années
passent et le djihadiste continuent
d'échapper aux américains jusqu'à ce 2
mai 2011
la nouvelle a pris tout le monde par
surprise à commencer par les américains
eux mêmes
dix ans de traque ben laden et localiser
l'homme se trouve dans une villa près
d'abbotabad au nord du pakistan en
pleine nuit ben laden est tué par une
équipe de navy seals les forces
spéciales américaines plusieurs
explosions ont eu lieu l'assaut a été
lancé par un commando héliporté les
combats vont durer quarante minutes
après des échanges de coups de feu
oussama ben laden l'un de ses fils et
trois autres personnes sont tuées
l'assaut terminé la dépouille de ben
laden et récupéré par l'équipe de navy
seals son corps a été immergé dès le
lendemain dans la mer d'arabie depuis un
porte-avions américain
[Musique]